- Hey everyone, I hope
you're having an amazing day.
It's Mark Wiens, I'm in Bangkok, Thailand
and tonight I am at
Talad Rot Fai Ratchada,
which is the night market.
It's the train market.
This market is known for it's very unique
Thai street food, as well as
it's gigantic portions of food.
Tonight we're gonna walk around,
we're gonna eat some street food,
but I'm mainly here to eat
a dish called Laeng Saeb.
And I'm gonna share it all with you
in this video, right now.
(uptempo music)
Now, you might remember
in the previous video,
I came to this market and we ate the most
over-sized, gigantic
bowl of lobster tom yum,
that you've ever seen.
And it was definitely a lot of fun to eat,
but the problem is that we
were so full after eating that,
that really nothing even
looked good after that.
So, I decided to make a part two.
We're back at Talad Rot Fai Ratchada.
This is the train,
night market in Bangkok,
known for it's unique Thai street food.
And I'm here to eat another unique food,
it's gonna be another giant bowl,
but completely different
and we're gonna try it at this market
where it's most famous.
The train-night market is especially known
for very unique Thai dishes.
You'll find a lot of dishes that
people kind of experiment with,
people come up with,
things are invented here.
So, apart from like authentic Thai food,
you'll find a lot of unique
creations that you'll
only find at this market.
Oh, and here we are, this is the spot.
(music)
(speaking in foreign language)
And the menu is on a giant cardboard.
They have medium, large,
XL, and they have XXL.
We're going straight for the XXL.
(swing music)
Oh wow, they just pulled out the plate,
it's not even a bowl it's a plate
that's like the size of a satellite dish.
(swing music)
they're stacking it up,
it looks like a tipi.
In a triangular fashion,
into a cone shape,
that is just getting more and
more ridicules by the second.
(uptempo music)
They literally take pots
and there like buckets,
and they mix up the soup broth
with crushed green chilies
and just literally anoint
that, just dump it on,
just fully coating it in a
layer of chilies and that soup.
(uptempo music)
Are you ready for this?
- Yes, can eat right now?
(uptempo music)
Taste very, very good, but
it's not that it look crazy,
but it taste very very good also.
- [Mark] This is one of the
most ridicules plates of food,
single plates of food I've
ever seen in my entire life.
It's literally a mountain of food.
Can you even see the whole thing?
Honest, he looked like he was struggling
when he carried it to the table.
This thing must be heavy,
I'm just gonna lift it a little bit.
Oh yeah, wow.
That not only weighs a
lot, but it's kind of like
it works on your motor skills too,
because you have to balance it.
You've got liquid in there,
you've got the bones,
this is a Mount Everest,
of pork bones and chilies.
And the amount of chilies
that they added on here
I think it would be uncountable.
There's like thousands
of chilies on this plate.
Before I get started
eating, before I taste this,
I just wanna tell
quickly about Laeng Saeb,
which is this dish.
It's actually a very
recent, modern Thai dish,
that's only been around for a
couple of years now, I think.
Or at least that's only been popular.
What it is, is it's the
pork bones, the pork spines.
A lot of the bones that
would just tossed out,
which are then boiled into a soup.
But, it looks like there might be
quite a bit of meat on these bones.
But then, it's boiled into a soup,
the soup is known to be very
spicy, full of lime juice.
Okay, it's time to start digging in.
I just wanna do a glory lap,
revolve around this first,
to see where is a good place to start.
Oh man, this is.
Okay, I think I found the spot.
Right down here where there's
a gigantic pool of chilies.
Seems like they should
be giving you a shovel
to eat this with rather than a spoon.
Okay, I'm gonna go in
just for the broth first.
And just look at that.
Yeah, that's just like solid
chilies with a little bit,
a little bit of cilantro in there.
Mm.
Oh yeah, It not only looks ridicules,
that is really good broth.
The chilies are spicy, but not that spicy.
It might look spicier than it is.
Yeah, okay, I can see how
that might build on you,
and that might grow into
a flame in your mouth.
Mm, but the broth you
can taste it's saltiness,
you taste that rich boney broth,
and then it's nice and sour as well.
I think I'll go in for
this bone right here,
where I can just kinda scrap it,
scrap it off the spine there.
Oh, yeah, that's guaranteed
to be just fall apart tender.
Look, just scrap that off the spine,
oh, into the pool below.
And what you can kinda do
is mix it with more chilies.
Oh, look at that, oh, that's a big bite.
(uptempo music)
Yeah, that pork is nice and tender.
Surprisingly, it tastes quite lean.
But maybe that's because all
the fat has rendered out,
has boiled down.
I think the next move to make,
would be to grab that whole bone and just.
Oh, look at that.
Okay, I'm just gonna
dip that into the soup,
rehydrate it a little bit.
(uptempo music)
I mean, there's not a tone
of meat on every bone,
but there are like 55 bones,
and that adds up to quite
a lot of meat, I think.
It's kinda easier to just take your bone,
and scrap of the meat.
Otherwise, it gets a little messy.
Making sure to scrap out
all those little crevices
all that meat.
Oh, that one just slide
right out of my fingers.
(Mark laughs)
It's not only really
good and looks ridicules,
it actually is a lot of fun to eat too.
I'll grab some of that meat,
I'll put this onto my rice,
add some more soup.
When you're scrapping
the meat off that bones,
it feels like a pork
avalanche, a meat avalanche
is happening with the
chilies and the meat.
If it were any bigger you
would need to harness up
and like climb onto this pile of bone.
(uptempo music)
The chili heat does start to build on you.
We've been eating for about 15 minutes
I think we're at least a quarter
of our way through the bones.
We have at least four
or five bones finished.
But, Ying's sister joined us now,
which we definitely need some
help, some reinforcements.
But this is, I mean, it is a lot of meat,
but it's kinda like a relaxing dish.
You just kinda nibble on the bones,
you kinda eat slowly, take
some bites of those chilies,
drink some of that soup.
And yes, you continue to eat those chilies
the heat does build.
It's lovely it's wonderful,
but the chilies are not,
I mean for the amount that you eat,
the chilies are not that spicy.
(uptempo music)
Yeah, at this point I'm
just so far deep in,
I'm gonna sit down the utilizes,
and just go in gnawing, and
digging out with my fingers.
Juicy bits of, just tenderness.
Ying is just pushing those chilies
down to my side of the plate.
Oh man, that is a
swimming pool of chilies.
That's so many chilies, that's insane.
As you keep on eating the top bones
start to get a little dry, so
you can kinda rehydrate them,
spoon on some chilies and some soup.
And you reach a certain
point where you just wanna
pick this up and just gnaw on it.
We've probably been eating for 45 minutes.
We're definitely getting closer.
I'd say we're at the finish point now.
You can almost see the
bottom of the plate.
There's just no way that I'm gonna be able
to finish all those chilies myself though.
That's an absurd amount of chilies.
- Try to give you something.
- [Mark] You're rehydrating.
(Ying laughs)
We have reached the finish line.
This is the final bone.
There's only a pool of soup
and still a ton of chilies down there.
But, yeah, I think we
climbed Mount Everest.
But, they sort of deceive you at the end.
They put all the bones with
the most meat at the bottom.
Look at how much meat that is.
Oh man, and it's like,
when you're at this stage,
you're just sort of like, oh,
you're just sort of like, slowly moving.
(uptempo music)
Mission accomplished,
I am drenched in sweat.
This place is extremely popular.
I don't think there's any empty tables.
(uptempo music)
It's so popular, that
now as we're leaving,
there's a waiting line.
It's a good thing we got here early.
Yeah, I'm definitely very full.
But it's, I mean it looks ginormous
because there's so many bones.
I mean, if you share that
with a few of people,
that's just a good solid meal.
But, yeah, it's just impressive
to look at, so many bones.
But I just wanna tell you
that Laeng Saeb, what a dish.
The combination of those green chilies,
the lime juice in there
and then boiled down those pork bones,
what a flavor combination,
what a flavor profile.
That is way more laeng saeb
than I ever care to eat again
in one sitting.
But, you should definitely try it.
It's an amazing dish.
And you can order all
sorts of different sizes.
Whatever size you desire for your meal.
We have stopped to eat
some, it's called Monster
(speaks in foreign language)
Monster (speaks in foreign language)
oh, okay, in Thai,
okay, it's the instant ice cream,
but in Thai that actually
means stir fried ice cream.
And that's actually exactly,
precisely, what it is.
(music)
What she does is she takes some milk,
she takes some other random ingredients
and then she kinda plays around with it.
That works it on the cold plate,
kinda flattens it out so it gets cold
and then scoops it back up.
And then the final step
is when she spreads it out
into a thin sheet and then
scraps it up from bottom,
into swirls.
She does some serious decorating though.
She but on some wafers some like
candy cane looking wafers.
Another Oreo, a bunch of whipped cream,
a bunch of chocolate sauce,
a bunch of sprinkles.
Did I miss anything.
I just wanna kinda taste
that ice cream first
and it is mixed.
What did we get Ying?
Almond and Oreo, right?
- [Ying] Uh-huh.
- Almond and Oreo in the ice cream.
This has been a very popular
trending type of ice cream
because of the way it's
made, for quite a while now.
But, this is my first time to try it.
I mean, it is ice cream,
but it's a little thinner.
It's not quite as rich.
(uptempo music)
I think it's a Wednesday night,
but traditionally this market
was more of a weekend market.
But now I think it's almost
open every night of the week.
I'm not totally sure.
But, it's open through out the week.
But coming here in the
week is really nice.
It's not nearly as busy.
The last time we came here
when we had the tom yum,
that was a Friday night.
Ah man, about this time,
at seven or eight p.m,
it just starts to get
like ridiculously packed.
To the point where you can barely move.
And there is so many people.
But now it's really manageable.
It's nice on the week days.
This snack is called
(speaks in foreign language).
Which, it translates
directly to crispy butter.
And this is a snack that's
very popular at this market.
If you walk through you'll find
a number of stalls selling it.
But I think the best part about
it is watching them make it.
It's pretty impressive.
I think they actually use cement trowels,
spread it out onto the hot plate.
The let it cook slowly.
Then he puts on a bunch of
butter with a paint brush,
they add on I think
sweeten condensed milk,
and then let it sizzle.
It's really like a paper thin sheet,
and then when it's done they scrap it up
into little like wafers.
In order to make this snack
you definitely need a lot of
construction materials,
trowels, paint brushes,
they're using it all.
Here they are the finished products.
These are like little,
little butter wafers.
Wow, yeah they're just paper thin.
They're the type of thing
that just completely collapses
as you bite down.
Mm.
It sort of like, goes down to nothing
when it touches with your saliva.
They do have a egg yolk taste to them.
(uptempo music)
those go down really easily.
And they're the type of thing
that kinda stick to your lips
if your lips are kinda dry.
(uptempo music)
I saw the coconut shakes and
this is just too tempting.
My mouth is still quite salty
from all of that Laeng Saeb.
And yeah, actually I'm pretty full,
so I think we might call it here.
End with a coconut, end on a good note,
with a coconut shake.
Oh, that's so naturally sweet.
That's just the sweetness
from the coconut water,
from the coconut meat, with ice in it.
Oh that hits the spot.
So that's gonna do it for this night,
street food tour of
Talad Rot Fai Ratchada.
The main goal of coming this evening
was to eat that Laeng Saeb.
And again, that was the most
gigantic, XXL version of it.
But you can order smaller
sizes, more manageable sizes,
and it's a great dish to eat.
And there's a lot of really
unique, really interesting
innovative, Thai street
foods to try at this market.
It's really worth checking
out when you're in Bangkok.
So I'm gonna end the video now.
Also, make sure you watch part one.
The absolutely giganormous
bowl of lobster tom yum.
I will link it below, but check that out.
Check out both of the videos
and I wanna say big thank
you for watching this video.
Please remember to give it a
thumbs up, if you enjoyed it.
Leave a comment below,
I'd love to hear from you.
And if you're not already
subscribed, click subscribe now.
I'm gonna be publishing lot's
more food and travel videos
and also click that little bell icon
so that you get notified of
the next video that I publish.
Thanks again for watching, good night.
See you on the next video.